antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir la mort d'un grand
champion jacques anquetil nous a quittés
ce matin il avait 53 ans
en août ils adorent et les défis la
provocation les exploits jusqu'au bout
il a fait preuve de courage et de
lucidité
ce
les dirigeants des partis politiques
invités par jacques chirac pour
réfléchir à la question du financement
de leur organisation
tous ont répondu favorablement déficit
commercial de la france 4 9 milliards de
francs en octobre l'augmentation des
importations face au tassement des
exportations explique ce mauvais chiffre
trois juges et non plus un seul pour
décider de la mise en détention
préventive
la réforme challandes ont adopté en
conseil des ministres sera appliquée en
89 si elle est votée par le parlement
arrivé en france du vice président
éthiopien son pays victime de la
sécheresse est à nouveau menacée par une
grave famine
les secours arrivent difficilement une
journée supplémentaire de détention pour
marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
la mort de jacques anquetil les pleurs
de raymond poulidor avant de partir aux
antilles où il est actuellement en
voyage raymond poulidor avait passé un
petit coup de fil à son ancien rival et
ami pour prendre de ses nouvelles
anquetil lui avait simplement répondu je
souffre et c'est encore plus dur que
dans le puy-de-dôme en 1964 réflexion
terrible surtout quand on a encore en
tête la force de certaines images gens
meurent
s'il reste une image du tour de france
nul doute que ce sera celle du puy de
dome le jour où s'est joué le tour de
france 1964
les deux hommes sont au coude à coude au
bord de l'épuisement jacques anquetil
maillot jaune dans un jour sans repousse
l'échéance jusqu'au bout de ses forces
polydor dans les derniers mètres le
lâche mais pas suffisamment
pour prendre la tête du classement
général à l'arrivée 14 secondes séparent
les deux hommes et divise définitivement
la france en deux c'est très difficile
dans des circonstances aussi pénible de
parler au passé d'un champion aussi
exceptionnel que jacques anquetil comme
tout le monde le sait nous avons divisé
la france en deux il y avait 50% dans
une playlist 50% de poulidor
mais je crois qu'on a surtout servi la
cause du cyclisme mais ça fait
énormément de bien pour le développement
du cyclisme heures en france et au delà
je crois que jacques annaud qui l'on
représente le cyclisme représente
énormément dans le cyclisme on garde un
souvenir de lui surtout ses cinq
victoires dans le tour de france et son
fabuleux doublé qu'il avait réussi à la
suite d'un dauphiné libéré bordeaux
paris oui toute la vie de jacques
anquetil et à l'image de son duel avec
raymond poulidor anquetil s'était le
courage alliée à la lucidité
très tôt il avait fort bien compris
qu'il fallait économiser ses efforts et
surtout ne pas se disperser
l'opinion publique ne l'avait pas
toujours très bien compris jean paul
ollivier c'est exact puisque en vérité
s'il en a de lui cette image elle est un
peu simpliste car lorsque les
organisateurs du tour de france cycliste
ont décidé pour précisément barrer la
route à jacques anquetil qui gagne au
millimètre comme l'ont dit ou à la
seconde près eh bien lorsque ses
organisateurs du tour de france ont
décidé de faire un tour de france
montagneux en évitant les étapes contre
la montre en tout cas en les réduisant
et bien jacques anquetil a quand même
gagné puisqu'il avait battu bahamontès
nous le voyons ici contre le facteur
temps lorsqu'il apparut soudain tout ce
que le cyclisme comptait de grand devin
ridiculement petit son style touchette à
la perfection
il donnait envie de pédaler partait à la
conquête du temps par des moyennes
fantastique comme on part pour une
partie de campagne le public regardez
admirez mais reste est incrédule pour
préférer poulidor parce que cet aigle
baisser la tête alors que lui anctil
orgueilleux mais peu ambitieux baissait
pas c'est le buste haut en défiant
l'équilibré la raison le public ne
trouvait pas en lui le défaut dans la
cuirasse qu'ils aient pu lui donner une
touche humaine
il semblait froid comme une statue
antique
homme de défis ils avançaient là où les
autres reculait car jacques anquetil et
mais le jeu il aimait les pari fou il
brûlait la vie
il lui fallut toujours dans la conquête
du temps selon jean cocteau du feu et
des diamants
et en plus de la rue quelques l élégant
sur le vélo dans la vie comme sur la
route anctil a fait preuve d'une force
de caractère extraordinaire vous pouvez
en témoigner à travers du vécu à travers
des anecdotes vous connaissez très bien
jacques oui vous savez c'est vrai que
vous avez raison de le souligner il
était l'homme des défis mais il était
l'homme des défis partout je crois que à
la fin du xxème siècle quand on
désignera peut-être dix hommes parmi les
plus grands les plus exceptionnels il
faudra cité anctil parce qu'il défiait
tout il défiait les grands sur la route
il défiait les grand contre la montre il
défiait les grands au sprint il défie
les grands aux montagnes et puis dans la
vie dans la vie il était fantastique
savez on lui signalait un buveur un jour
un buveur invétéré et bien le 10ème à
celui là je vais le battre il le prenait
et puis la nuit durant
il le battait il battait les meilleurs
buveurs dans leur propre aux estaminets
il battait les plus gros mangeurs dans
leur propre robert il était exceptionnel
en tout et peut être par là at il fait
son propre malheur mais je crois que
c'était un être fait pour être
exceptionnel la dernière ligne droite de
jacques anquetil quelque part en nommant
en normandie avec bruno gex ici est 1 en
3 minutes tranquillement paisiblement
j'ai pas sans souffrance ça a été
c'était une mort très douce et puis je
préfère t il très bien comme ça il avait
de l'espoir encore hier et il s'est
battu peut-être même mieux que la moitié
à la moyenne des cancéreux qui sont déjà
des gens très très courageux en règle
générale mais lui a fait près de 2
une détermination faisons pas de doute
en faillite
c'est un grand champion qui est qui qui
se battaient là c'est évident et
toujours une attitude même dans les
moments ils ont ils avaient le moral qui
flanche un peu il se raccroche est
toujours intéressant s'est montrée
sportif jusqu'au bout évidemment quand
on rencontre des gens comme ça on
pourrait croire que que c'est des gens à
touches a b puis au fait c'est moi je
vous dis pour moi c'était un ami armand
la disparition d'un grand champion aura
suscité autant de réactions pour
françois mitterrand la france a perdu
l'un de ses fils les plus remarquables
dès ce matin le premier ministre jacques
chirac avait affirmé je cite ces propos
anquetil restera un grand modèle pour la
france
beaucoup de télégrammes vous l'avez vu
une émotion à peine contenue dans tous
ces télégrammes et les amis qui avaient
du mal à trouver les mots
ce matin on ne réalise pas immédiatement
on ne le crois pas et je crois que c'est
à cela pour mesurer l'affection que l'on
pouvait porter à venir quelqu'un qui
tout à coup ne sera plus là je me fais
pas l'idée d'une course cycliste
maintenant changea compte sans jacques
anquetil
j'ai du mal pendant dix ans nous avons
été jeunes hommes ensemble copains amis
nous étions
dans les bons dans les meilleurs moments
nous étions toujours ensemble et pour
moi c'est une page qui tentant de
tourner et on mange ensuite revenu
superbement vente a mis le copain je
suis triste et sur paris ce que je
crains des liens particuliers avec je
suis le parrain de son fils et tout ça
ça me touche
on a l'impression qu'on paie recul comme
sa famille parce que il était tellement
connue et en plus comme j'aime bien le
vélo on sait très bien depuis ses
boubous chenu comme interviewer
aujourd'hui séparément sans lui
lady n'aviez pas envie de venir pas
tellement au pire je me suis dit c'est
bon vous savez j'écoute est justement le
requiem de mozart vous voyez ce matin
dans mes écouteurs un petit hommage que
je rends comme ça
enfin
on y dit au revoir les obsèques du grand
champion jacques anquetil auront lieu
vendredi prochain dans la région
rouennaise nos confrères de l'équipe et
du sport publie bien sûr des numéros
tout à fait exceptionnel on va montrer
la morasse en avant-première oui le
sport made you jacques et en ce qui
concerne l'équipe l'affalage et en
présente avec des quizz au beurre
l'équipe de france en 1958 il a fait
aussi en 59
et puis avec son fils christopher son
fils de 18 mois merci voyons rapidement
les autres faits marquants de
l'actualité en commençant par la
politique à l'assemblée nouvelle passe
d'armes majorité opposition autour du
financement des partis politiques
mais le fait nouveau nous arrive en
droite ligne de matignon on vient
d'apprendre que jacques chirac invité
les chefs des partis à se réunir afin
d'arrêter une procédure la formation
sera publié demain champ chez nos
confrères du figaro
déjà une première réaction celle de
lionel jospin lionel jospin est tout à
fait prêts à répondre à cette offre à
cette offre comme les autres d'ailleurs
nous notre objectif c'est pas que en
noix le poisson c'est que c'est qu'on
arrive à quelque chose avant l'élection
présidentielle
c'est à dire que à un consensus se
dégage ou qu'une majorité se dégage sur
un ou des projets concernant soit le
financement des partis politiques soit
en tout cas et à court terme le contrôle
et la limitation des dépenses pour la
campagne présidentielle justement si
c'est ça l'intention des partis de la
majorité alors nous sommes prêts le
premier ministre va essayer entre les
différents partis dé dégager un
consensus est donc l'objet de la table
ronde de ses devoirs à quelles
conditions peut exister ce consensus
nous allons venir l'esprit ouvert et
constructif
nous avons demandé depuis longtemps
qu'il y ait cette réforme sans être dupe
de la mascarade organisée par monsieur
chirac nous nous rendrons jean marie le
pen se rendra à son invitation
nous sommes prêts et nous livrons valoir
c'est à dire la reconnaissance du
fondement démocratique de la partie
troisièmement nous considérons qu'il
faut leur campagne électorale
voilà le président françois mitterrand
considère que les trois mois qui
précèdent l'ouverture réelle de la
campagne présidentielle sont suffisants
pour permettre au parlement d'adopter
une loi sur le financement des partis et
des campagnes électorales il l'a redit
tout à l'heure devant les préfets qui
étaient réunis à l'elysée je vous
propose d'écouter très vite une autre
réaction celle de jean lecanuet elle
vient de nous parvenir
bien entendu que je me rendrai à son
invitation
cette invitation est d'ailleurs dans la
ligne de notre entretien dit hier à
matignon
elle présente davantage de reprendre
l'initiative et de faire apparaître le
comportement du président de la
république était une tentative qui va
disparaître du fait de l'initiative du
gouvernement pour faire oublier que le
parti qui a sa préférence
le parti socialiste est quelque peu
exposé aux critiques sur le financement
des partis
sur ce point que la jst voilà c'était
donc jean le cam une réaction qui vient
de nous parvenir paul amar l'initiative
de jacques chirac après celle du chef de
l'état françois mitterrand est ce que
c'est réellement une surprise
une demi surprise l'initiative de
jacques chirac est en fait destiné à
effacer l'impression provoqué hier par
l'attitude de la majorité est là c'est
vrai donner le sentiment de traîner les
pieds et de ne pas vouloir adopter une
loi sur le financement des partis avant
l'élection présidentielle elle était en
fête
irrité par la contre offensive de
françois mitterrand qui a fait mouche et
il n'était pas question pour elle
d'obtenir et sur le champ et d'exaucer
le voeu présidentielle mais les français
ont perçu davantage l'embarras que
l'irritation et le premier ministre sans
doute conscient de l'effet néfaste d'une
telle attitude a voulu le corrigé
aujourd'hui en reprenant à son tour
l'initiative l'élection présidentielle
s'annonce comme une belle guerre de
mouvement
il invite donc vous l'avez dit les chefs
de partis à se réunir avec lui et ils
souhaitent la conclusion de l'accord sur
cette question délicate
on a envie de dire chiche cela fait des
années que les hommes politiques
promettent de dire d'où vient l'argent
cela fait des années qu'ils promettent
un vrai contrôle de leur financement
mais c'est sans doute la promesse l'a
maintenu en france cette arlésienne
vous êtes en quelque sorte de l'objet
d'un consensus entre tous les partis
mais cette fois la classe politique a
semble-t-il compris qu'elle ne pouvait
plus jouer avec le feu elle ne peut pas
dénoncer les scandales
c'est à dire les détournements de fonds
publics à des fins électorales et ne
rien faire pour les éviter
c'est une contradiction que l'opinion
publique condamne aujourd'hui c'est une
contradiction que les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle devront
résoudre avant d'entamer leur ronde
électorale à grands frais à quels frais
merci un mauvais chiffres 4,9 milliards
de francs en octobre c'est le déficit du
commerce extérieur aux dires des
spécialistes l'aggravation provient
d'une baisse des exportations de l'ordre
de 0 9% et d'une augmentation des
importations de 2 3% depuis le début de
l'année le déficit atteint 31,2
milliards de francs un chiffre qui est
jugé préoccupant par jacques chirac
edouard balladur plus nuancée parle de
résultats moins satisfaisant que prévu
michel noir le ministre de tutelle du
commerce extérieur déclare gardons le
moral et achetons français mauvais
chiffres pour le commerce extérieur ça
c'est le constat pour mieux vous faire
comprendre ce chiffre nous allons
paradoxalement
nous arrêter sur le cas d'une entreprise
qui réalise tenez vous bien 100 % de son
chiffre d'affaires à l'exportation
cas unique mais pas spécialement
réconfortant pour nos couleurs
reportage de jean pierre métivet et
bernie mériaux pour voir cette machine
révolutionnaire ou vient du monde entier
cette fois les visiteurs sont japonais
mais pas une semaine sans que des
industriels américains suédois ou
coréens de vienne dans cette petite
entreprise de grenoble attention
photographies est interdite
on a même dissimulé les éléments
sensibles de la machine sous des caches
le pdg méfiant un client potentiel peut
parfois cacher quelqu'un d'autre que
nous savons nous risquons d'avoir des
copieurs éventuel nous arrive de monter
sur nos machines certains équipements
sur lesquels nous avons eu des petits
problèmes comme ça nous ne disons pas
s'ils veulent nous copier
on leur fait un petit cadeau quoi le
secret de cette machine révolutionnaire
ces minuscules jets d'eau qui sont
autant de véritables aiguilles pour
assembler les matières synthétiques les
nantis c'est une technique qui permet de
créer de nouveaux produits depuis 1983
ces machines ont toutes été vendues à
l'étranger en rfa aux états unis en
grande bretagne et rien en france
l'entreprise vient tout juste de fêter
son premier client français presque un
tour de force
selon le pdg je pense que si sur notre
main notre matériel il était écrit
nadine un autre pays et je dirais
germany et sociale ares par exemple je
pense qu'il serait beaucoup plus facile
de le vendre en france
oui je crois qu'on n'est pas très
nationaliste
l'entreprise ne rédigent même plus sa
documentation en français seulement en
anglais et japonais
inquiétant sur ce marché les français
seront finalement les derniers à
s'équiper d'une technique d'avant-garde
un cas révélateur du retard à
l'investissement en france cette année
seulement nous rattraperons le niveau
d'investissement de 1981 mais l'écart
avec nos concurrents étrangers lui
n'aura pas été rattrapé le projet de
réforme de l'instruction enchères au
garde des sceaux monsieur albin
chalandon a été présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres le texte réforme
la procédure qui est actuellement en
vigueur
en deux mots disons que le juge
d'instruction garde la conduite de
l'information judiciaire mais qu'il est
dessaisi de ses prérogatives en matière
de détention provisoire au profit de
trois juges explications et réactions
avec jérôme kamini désormais si la
loyauté le juge d'instruction qui
s'interroge sur un éventuel placement en
détention provisoire
fera appel à trois de ses confrères
trois juges qui n'ont pas instruit le
dossier
trois juges qui auront trois jours pour
se réunir mais dans la réalité
la loi est-elle applicable ce projet de
loi est à la fois pervers et
inapplicable il est pervers car chaque
année les tribunaux correctionnels déjà
surchargés devront statuer dans 55
milles à faire de plus il est également
inapplicable dans des petites
juridictions comme seul nom on avait
beaucoup parlé à quelques années
hassebroucq où il n'y a que trois juges
dans ce tribunal
lorsque ces trois juges auront statué
pour délivrer mandat de dépôt il n'y
aura plus un seul juge
pour juger l'affairé au fond quelques
mois plus tard en correctionnelle les
juges qui ont le sentiment d'être visés
depuis quelques temps réagissent avec
fermeté première réaction aucune
concertation nous avons demandé la
communication du texte pour faire valoir
nos observations on nous l'a refusé
deuxième observation il existe déjà un
texte de loi qui a été votée à
l'unanimité par le parlement et qu'il
devrait rentrer en application en
janvier 88 le garde des sceaux a dit
qu'il ne serait pas mise en application
parce qu'ils étaient trop coûteux en
personnel son texte est aussi coûteux en
personnel pourquoi ne veut-il pas
appliquer le texte de loi qui existe
déjà
sans doute parce qu'il s'appelle loi
badinter si les dispositions challandes
ont été votés elle entrera en vigueur
dans moins de deux ans en mars quatre
lames l'étranger en bref le raid iranien
contre un hôpital au nord-est de l'irak
a fait neuf morts et 64 blessés le porte
parole de l'agencé iranienne
l'information a estimé que le
bombardement de l'établissement était
délibéré il a demandé à l'opinion
publique internationale de dénoncer ce
crime en images voyons les autres
télégramme de l'étranger avec isabelle
staes
le scandale de l'irangate avec la
publication aujourd'hui du rapport du
congrès américain ronald reagan
accusé de négligence mais pas d'acte
illégal compromettant son mandat le
président américain n'a pas fait
respecter la loi mais rien ne permet
d'affirmer qu'il était au courant des
ventes d'armes américaines à l'iran cent
mille grecs dans la rue athènes
commémore la révolte étudiante contre
les militaires elle avait fait 44 morts
en novembre 73 les manifestants ont
accusé les états unis d'être le
principal instigateur de la dictature
cinq personnes ont été blessées
le rapt de mélodies l'ultimatum a pris
fin hier soir les ravisseurs ont baissé
la rançon à 5 millions de dollars au
lieu de 13 depuis aucune nouvelle
on s'interroge aujourd'hui sur le passé
du père de mélodies le milliardaire n'a
qu'à tian un quotidien espagnol la
cuisse d'être un ancien proxénète
le vice président de la république
d'ethiopie fils et cas des stars a été
reçue tout à l'heure au palais de
l'elysée à paris au cours de son
entretien avec françois mitterrand il a
longuement évoqué la situation
dramatique de son pays
sur place il faut agir vite et on a
souvent reproché à l'ethiopie de cacher
sa misère
maintenant il semble bien que cette
image soit un peu dépassé dominique
torrès est l'une de nos équipes témoigne
sur le terrain
voici les premiers secours qui arrivent
au port de massaoua au nord de
l'ethiopie première aide internationale
après six mois de silence d'un silence
réprobateur victimes à la fois de
certaines erreurs lui aussi d'une
campagne de presse négatif l'ethiopie le
pays d'afrique qui reçoit le moins dead
9 dollars par personne et par an pour 20
$ pour la moyenne de l'afrique
tirant la leçon des maladresses passé
l'ethiopie semble bien décider
aujourd'hui à prendre les devants afin
de ne plus se retrouver devant la
situation catastrophique
il ya quatre ans comme vous pouvez le
voir la nourriture commençaient à
arriver sur le plan logistique démarrer
les opérations dès que d'autres vivres
nous parviendrons des camions remis en
état
me sens en gares prévues logistique
établi toutefois l'insuffisance du
réseau routier et l' isolement du
village poseront forcément de sérieux
problèmes d'acheminement
il faut compter quatre mois pour faire
parvenir l'aide internationale
l'une est absolument nécessaire même si
le pays s'organisent pour faire face à
la sécheresse comme ici asmara la
capitale de l'erythrée ou des camions
citernes apporte l'eau aux habitants de
la ville et de ses environs
les experts internationaux sont formels
la famine qui va s'abattre sur
l'ethiopie pour dépasser en horreur la
précédente 950 mille tonnes de céréales
sont nécessaires il faut agir vite
voilà tout à l'heure françois mitterrand
a assuré le vice président éthiopien
d'une aide française la france livrera
8000 tonnes de céréales dans les jours
qui viennent
en plus de l'effort consenti par la cee
85% des français favorables à
l'euthanasie c'est un sondage sofres qui
le révèle aujourd'hui dans les colonnes
de notre confrère france soir à la
question souhaitez vous être aidé à
mourir en cas de maladies incurables
58% des français répondent oui
certainement 21 % oui probablement
13 % non sondages et réactions avec
daniel duigou la mort n'est plus un
sujet tabou c'est ce qu'indique la très
forte majorité pour l'euthanasie et
surtout la très grande cohérence des
réponses des français au sondage quel
que soit l'âge ou le sexe les
convictions politiques ou religieuses
comment mourir 63% des français sont
pour l'euthanasie active c'est-à-dire
pour la prise d'un médicament 27% sur
pour l'euthanasie passive c'est-à-dire
en fait contre l'acharnement
thérapeutique dans le cas de souffrance
atroce sans espoir de guérison qui doit
prendre la décision les avis sont plus
partagés pour 46% des français c'est aux
médecins de prendre la décision
pour 37% 7 au malade lui-même mais dans
le cas où le malade est dans
l'incapacité de décider 79% des français
estiment qu'il faut suivre sa volonté
exprimée par écrit avant la maladie
15 % s'y opposent parce que le malade
n'est plus en mesure de confirmer sa
décision
du côté des associations qui sont pour
l'euthanasie on se félicite bien sûr du
sondage new york dans un environnement
évidemment judéo-chrétien longtemps les
prêtres ont régné sur la mort longtemps
après ce sont les médecins qui ont régné
sur la mort aujourd'hui
l'omc a le souci de conquérir de
nouveaux espaces de liberté prend pas en
compte pleinement responsable sa propre
mort mais du côté des associations qui
sont contre l'euthanasie on rappelle
qu'il existe des moyens de mourir sans
souffrir
la veille un malade peut souffrir et
demandé pour mettre fin à sa vie
le lendemain s'ils ne souffrent plus et
n'a plus du tout
c'est une chose de réfléchir à froid sur
la mort c'en est une autre de prendre la
décision au moment venu
ce n'est plus alors une histoire de
sondages ni de loi mais un choix
personnel
l'actualité sportive en deux mots jean
ma mère on joue au football en ce moment
au parc des princes on va tout de suite
voir les images derrière nous ça donne
quoi on joue contre la rda très bien
pour l'instant il y à 0 à 0 entre les
deux équipes la france et la rda vous
découvrez ici joue elle bat le gardien
de l'équipe de france les français
jouent en bleu et les allemands de l'est
joue en blanc domination pour l'instant
des français même s'ils n'ont pas
concrétisé
cependant la plus chaude actions et à
mettre à leur actif avec un tir de
bellonne de 25 mètres sur le poteau
gauche du gardien muller égard
l'allemand de l'est sur un coup-franc
d'amour hausse pour l'instant les
français dominent mais ont du mal à
vraiment bien organisé leur je veux dire
qu'ils se heurtent à une défense est
allemand assez assez fermé et je
rappelle que le match aller s'était
soldé par un match nul 0 0 entre les
deux équipes même si ce match n'a pas
une grande importance ce soir il serait
tout de même bon pour les français
d'inscrire une victoire c'est sûr c'est
très bon pour le moral
malheureusement sur ce nouveau coup
franc français c'est le troisième pas de
concrétisation de vue voilà 00 hockey ou
en depuis vingt-six minutes maintenant
l'image résultats et commentaires dans
le journal de 23h30 avec aubry et de
l'air on enchaîne avec les pronostics du
quarté en cour demain à vincennes dans
le prix de l'or n'est ce qui a toujours
aussi peu de chevaux au départ mais non
justement un 6/6 à auteuil ont peur le
manque de particules contraire on est
obligé de doubler les courses tellement
il ya de chevaux 19 chevaux demain vont
courir dans le quartier à vincennes dans
le prix de l'orne sur une distance de
2300 m ces trotteurs sont vraiment très
connus des turfistes sont toujours les
mêmes qu'on voit dans ce style d'épreuve
donc la course promet d'être très
ouverte
alors attention il y aura sûrement un ou
deux auteurs qui se glisseront à
l'arrivée et justement c'est ce que
j'essayais de trouver dans le pronostic
que je vous propose maintenant avec en
tête quirinus des skis le numéro 5 suivi
de cas maria le disque à sida dupont le
19 kg n'a que quatorze questions mazurie
le 3 qui giteau le 13 quinte devrient le
15 et pour terminer catarrhale numéro 16
5 10 19 14 3 13
15 et 16 parfait la météo laurent ça se
gâte
malheureusement oui effectivement ça se
gâte par le nord car nous changerons de
régime en fait nous avions un
anticyclone et je vous en parle depuis
longtemps cet anticyclone est en train
de s'affaiblir de s'affaisser sur le
nord de la france c'est pourquoi demain
dès demain après midi
nous aurons quelques nuages et même des
pluies sur certaines régions que je vais
vous indiquez ici comme là non à la
haute normandie le nord et la picardie
dans toutes ces contrées donc des ondées
et puis nous aurons ensuite un dégradé
nuageux au fur et à mesure que nous
descendrons vers le midi de la france
avec un large soleil quand même puisque
l'anticyclone sera encore là un large
soleil sur les régions méridionales les
températures pour demain elle fait bis
elle commence à chuter elles vont chuter
encore plus après de même enfin dès
demain 10 à 15 degrés sur les régions de
la moitié nord de la france et nous
irons de le 12 à 20 degrés sur la moitié
sud
je laisse observer ces températures en
vous indiquant qu'il y aura des gelées
demain matin à clermont ferrand toulouse
limoges et bordeaux
et puis aujourd'hui le ciel si vous
allez sur une petite commune de la
creuse
cette commune s'appelle le champion le
soleil incliné ses rayons sur le
champion au soleil qui demain se lèvera
quand même à 8h06 et se couchera à 17h05
nous fêterons pelé tanguy mais aussi
l'arrivée du beaujolais nouveau et ça
c'est important
prochain rendez vous d'information 23h30
avec aubry et de l'air demain dès 6h45
n'oubliez pas télématin avec catherine
ceylac trop jézabel et marc hautement à
7h45
monsieur joxe pierre joxe président du
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale sera l'invité des 4 vérités
merci de votre fidélité et à demain 20h
bonsoir
là